[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end sur tv 78 actualité idées de
sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines voici le programme de
ce 29 avril
des formations gratuites pour utiliser
son ordinateur ou son smartphone se
familiariser avec les outils en ligne le
digitroc si la france pour l'avs pour
lutter contre la fracture numérique il
faisait étape cette semaine à maurepas
avant d'autres passages prévus dans les
yvelines face à l'enlisement de la
guerre en ukraine des députés ont écrit
à leur homologue russe de la dubai les
appels à intercéder auprès de vladimir
poutine pour un cessez le feu un
courrier à l'initiative de la députée
des yvelines natalia pouzy rêve qui est
notre invité et puis comme tous les
vendredis nos idées de sorties pour
samedi et dimanche dans le département
alors que les petits yvelinois ont
encore une semaine de vacances scolaires
et ce sera bien sûr dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission avec mon
acolyte chaque vendredi bixente maillot
santisteban bonjour bixente jean grégory
une mission si vous l'acceptez encore
aujourd'hui c'est donné l'envi de sortir
à nos téléspectateurs comment
comptez-vous y parvenir comme vous
l'avez dit gregory les vacances suivent
leurs cours dans le département et c'est
l'occasion pour les yvelinois de lancer
de nouvelles choses une pompe parlera
par exemple une première randonnée ou
d'un nouvel escape game et ce sera tout
à l'heure bien sûr dans le sais tu ce
week end
après les hauts-de-seine le digitroc qui
était de passage dans les yvelines
jusqu'à ce vendredi à maurepas plus
précisément ce camion itinérant permet
de se former au numérique et
gratuitement se connecte à internet
utiliser son ordinateur son smartphone
tout ça n'aura plus de secrets pour vous
le reportage de mathilde francou et de
bixente mayence insisté ban
se connecter à sa boîte mail envoyé un
sms utiliser son ordinateur ses gestes
qui font partie de notre quotidien ne
sont pas forcément évident pour tous du
19 au 30 avril le digi trucks propose
des formations gratuites au numérique à
maurepas que j'ai appris c'est que
beaucoup de choses et surtout un
professeur des professeurs à nous aider
à
avec beaucoup de patience très bien
passé même si on a quelques notions
trop fermé ya toujours des va très vite
un les mises à jour sont toujours
paniquer ce camion itinérant anime des
ateliers de 1h30 à trois heures pour
aider les participants à se familiariser
au digital là par exemple aujourd'hui
c'était ce matin c'était créer et
envoyer des emails cet après midi c'est
à rechercher internet et en fin de
journée on a vu les applications on
s'adapte aussi par le comte cet après
midi comme j'ai dit le programme on a
aussi pas mal de personnes qui pouvaient
pas venir ce matin pour la boîte email
pas du coup on a refait ce qu'on a vu ce
matin il n'y a pas de souci quand on
s'adapte au total une centaine de
participants ont pu bénéficier de ses
conseils personnalisés dans la commune
une initiative de l'entreprise de
télécommunications huawei l'objectif de
cette étude tracks séparément a mené la
formation
dans les quartiers en fait récupéré dans
les quartiers prioritaires des villes ça
fait déjà quelques jours que le digitroc
est installé à maurepas et on se rend
compte qu'il ya vraiment une utilité
sociale parce que je le rappelle c'est
quand même dit cette portion de la
population qui est quand même concernés
en france contre lille électro nisme
comme on dit d'autres ateliers peuvent
aussi être organisée en fonction de la
demande comme être en forme son cv ou se
familiariser avec d'octo libre prochaine
étape dans les yvelines poissy du 27
juin au 9 juillet
un conflit qui semble aujourd'hui sans
issue depuis le 24 février la guerre
sévit en ukraine plus de 5 millions de
réfugiés des négociations qui patine
entre l'ukraine et la russie dernière
preuve de cet enlisement de nouvelles
frappes russes qui ont frappé jeudi kiev
au moment où le secrétaire général de
l'onu antonio guterres s était en visite
et des députés français ont une autre
approche le 21 avril dernier ils ont
envoyé un courrier à leurs homologues
russes de la douma l'objectif les
appeler à intercéder auprès de vladimir
poutine pour un cessez-le-feu à
l'initiative de ce courrier natalia
pouzy rêve qui est notre invité par
visioconférence bonjour
vous êtes député la république en marge
de la 6ème circonscription des yvelines
membre de la commission des affaires
étrangères et aussi du groupe d'amitié
franco russe déjà une réaction à ces
nouvelles frappes qui ont touché kiev
qui ont fait au moins une victime une
productrice de radio ukrainienne et la
russie aussi qui dans le même temps
continue son offensive à l'est et au sud
de l'ukraine et est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'on est dans un conflit
avec une une voie sans issue
et bien écoutez où on souhaiterait
qu'ils aient une désescalade de ce
conflit mais malheureusement la russie
est parti dans une logique de guerre et
on voit bien que malgré des déclarations
sur une imitation en fait des frappes au
donbass mais n'en est rien et on peut
imaginer que tu mens kiev pas continuer
à être frappés on peut imaginer que dans
l'esprit des russes il sera important de
prolonger aussi le couloir du dombass
jusqu'au sud et pourquoi pas jusqu'à
odessa donc les scénarios sont sont
nombreux et en fait il faut se préparer
à ce que ces conflits et ses complices
et frappe ce se poursuivre alors le 21
avril dernier le disait un courrier
rédigé à votre initiative et signé aussi
par quinze autres parlementaires a été
envoyée au député russe de la douma
pourquoi pourquoi cette initiative
pourquoi vous adresser à vos homologues
russes justement eh bien écoutez il me
semblait important de réagir face à
cette agression de l'ukraine par la
russie face aux exactions qui sont
commises face aux besoins de
l'évacuation humanitaire il me semblait
important de réagir et de le signifier à
nos homologues russes alors on se fait
pas beaucoup d'illusions sur la réponse
qu'il pourrait apporter mais il s'agit
il s'agit essentiellement de rappeler la
responsabilité qui leur incombe devant
l'histoire en ce qu on al impression qu
effectivement ces exactions ces crimes
de guerre se répète et que le peuple
russe lui même n'en est pas informée il
ya une chape de plomb qui pèse sur le
peuple russe vous savez que l'accès à
l'information n'est pas libre que la
propagande et majeurs en russie et les
relais les députés de la douma les
députés russes sans les représentants du
club donc je pense qu'il faut continuer
à s'adresser au peuple russe et c'est
pour ça que cette lettre j'espère
qu'elle pourra circuler en russie je
pense qu'il faut qu'elle circule aussi
auprès de la communauté française la
communauté russe pardon qui est en
france seule façon et que et que les
députés russes et bien compris que nous
condamnons fermement
les agressions de le plein par la hausse
je suis votre courrier il est essentiel
que les négociations entre la russie et
l'ukraine s'intensifie le président et
zelensky ayant fait part de concessions
que son pays serait prêt à faire pour
retrouver les conditions d'une stabilité
en europe continentale nous enjoignons
le parlement russe a formulé des
recommandations allant dans le sens d'un
apaisement et d'une résolution du
conflit vous croyez toujours en la
négociation parce qu'on al'impression ce
que je disais tout à l'heure on a un peu
au point mort alors on a appris
aujourd'hui que lors du prochain g20 le
président indonésien jocko widodo avait
invité justement les présidents russe et
ukrainien autour de la table c'est de
cette manière c'est par la négociation
qu'on sortira du conflit cesser votre
conviction il ya en tout cas la
négociation à l'oise placé entre les
ukrainiens et russes nous ne pouvons
qu'appeler à la négociation
effectivement des pays comme la turquie
l'indonésie maintenant mais vous savez
que le président français emmanuel
macron a essayé aussi d'intercéder en la
matière mais la négociation doit se
dérouler entre le président et line ce
qu'il appelle de ses voeux il il
souhaite rencontrer vladimir poutine et
c'est pour ça que nous adressons aux
députés russes pour qu'ils puissent
rendre cela possible en fait en temps de
guerre les négociations doivent se
poursuivre c'est la seule façon de
parvenir à un cessez-le-feu c'est qu'une
il faut qu'il y ait une résolution
politique qui se fasse alors la question
aussi humanitaire est essentiel c'est ce
que vous dites dans le courrier alors on
rappel des chiffres un plus de 5
millions de réfugiés ukrainien 8
millions d'ukrainiens déplacées à
l'intérieur
pays est aujourd'hui des centaines de
militaires et de civils ukrainiens sont
bloqués à marioupol dans l'usiné azote
stahl l'évacuation est envisagé un
toujours ce vendredi ça ce volet
humanitaire vous avez voulu le mettre en
avant ses symboles essentiels aussi dans
la résolution de ce conflit
absolument c'est que la ville de
mariupol a été quasiment rasé si ce
n'est ce complexe
qui est maintenu à qui existent encore
et qui a des des souterrains qui permet
d'abriter des civils et quelques
militaires également et il ya déjà eu
des tentatives de montées c'est d'ouvrir
ces corridors humanitaires d'évacuation
le président emmanuel macron d'ailleurs
s'était avancé sur cette avait avancé
cette proposition
les russes ont déclaré qu'ils allaient
ouvrir les corridas mais on voit bien
que le lendemain il se dédie donc il
faut continuer à faire pression
l'assocation à marie paule est
extrêmement préoccupante et je pense
qu'il faut que toute la communauté
internationale fasse pression pour que
ce corridor sont ouverts et que les
évacuations et lieu vers des
destinations qui ne soit pas que celle
de la russie mais aussi qu'ils aillent
vers des pays limitrophes qui sentait
accueillir pour ces réfugiés mais
d'ailleurs la justice ukrainienne juste
pour parler aussi de ce sujet à parler
aujourd'hui de 8000 un crime de guerre
présumés avec des images très dures on
le sait du côté de butch alors vous le
disais tout à l'heure ce sera ma
dernière question vous avez peu d'espoir
sur l'issue de ce courrier aujourd'hui
vous n'avez pas eu de réponse encore de
vos homologues russes j'ai peu d'espoir
d'avoir une réponse officielle
néanmoins ce qui est important comme je
disais c'est que ce courrier circule si
possible via sur auprès des russes le
plus largement possible mais aussi parmi
la communauté russe en france parce que
tous les jours ou tous les deux jours
moi je reçois des courriers de
l'ambassade de bossi en france qui sont
des courriers de propagande et je pense
que je ne faut pas dans cette guerre de
l'information si l'on peut dire il ne
faut pas baisser la garde et que nous
aussi nous devons pouvoir faire entendre
cette voix qui est effectivement d'un
soutien humanitaire aux victimes et
aussi un appel à cesser le feu il n'y a
pas de raison que seuls la propagande
russe circule en france donc voilà j'ai
pris apple contre-pied par cette
initiative et je tenais à rappeler aussi
que tous les crimes seraient documenter
la communauté internationale s'est
encore à et que la france et les autres
pays européens
appuieront effectivement les demandes de
jugement devant les tribunaux
internationaux
je vais aussi très justement le passage
en question de ce courrier un les
exactions commises à l'encontre de la
population ukrainienne par là mais
l'armée de la fédération de russie 1
feront l'objet d'un recueil de preuves
et nous veillerons à ce qu'elles soient
dûment documentés se pourrait-il que les
noms des représentants de la douma soit
cité en tribunal international pour
complicité l'histoire en jugera voici un
autre extrait de ce communiqué auquel
vous faisiez référence merci natalia
plaisir est d'avoir été avec nous merci
avant je le rappelle député de la 6e
circonscription des yvelines et à
l'initiative donc de ce courrier envoyé
aux députés russes de la douma retour à
présent sur les autres actualités de
cette semaine les faits marquants qui se
sont déroulées dans les yvelines s'est
dit charles vous résume le tout en 78
secondes la voix de michael ennemis dont
[Musique]
avions fait cette femme en situation de
handicap mental cohabitent dans une
maison fraîchement rénovée elles sont
accompagnées de deux maîtresses de
maison pour les superviser un projet qui
vise à favoriser leur inclusion top
départ pour le tour auto 2022 le rendez
vous des passionnés d'automobile 250
bolide de collection sont parties du
château de rambouillet nous rejoindrons
andorre-la-vieille samedi 30 après avoir
arpenté la france la ville de villepoix
lancé son premier budget participatif
une initiative qui permet aux habitants
de la ville de proposer leurs projets et
dossiers peuvent se déposer en mairie
jusqu'au 15 juin seront ensuite soumis à
un vote la tournée des sites olympiques
de paris 2024 a débuté au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le président du comité d'organisation
tony estanguet étaient présents sur
place pour rappel 50 ans neeve dispose
de quatre sites olympiques le vélodrome
nationale le stadium de bmx le golf
national et la colline des lampes pour
cet officiel au partenariat est signé
cessange à mansle et qui va accueillir
la délégation olympique de la team
grande bretagne pour les jeux olympiques
de paris 2024 les athlètes et les
membres du comité pourront s'entraîner
bénéficier d'équipements sportifs de
haut niveau
[Musique]
chaque vendredi dans le 7-8 week-end le
collectif des surligneurs décrypte
l'actualité quelques jours après la fin
des présidentielles raphaël mata
duvignau nous parle des comptes de
campagne et de leur contrôle c'est notre
rubrique légal checking
l'élection présentielle est terminée un
autre marathon commence maintenant celui
du contrôle des comptes de campagne et
du remboursement éventuel des frais
correspondants cela suppose non
seulement un plafonnement des
remboursements mais également un minimum
de représentativité des candidats d'où
le fameux seuil fatidique des 5%
c'est en réalité depuis 1988 que le
législateur finance les campagnes
électorales par l'argent public voyant
donc un contrôle ce contrôle est allouée
à la commission nationale des comptes de
campagne et des financements politiques
qui est une autorité administrative
indépendante dont l'une des missions est
d'encadrer strictement les comptes de
campagne pour la plupart des élections
l'encadrement est d'abord celui des dons
en vérité les personnes morales sociétés
ou associations ne peuvent pas donner et
pour les personnes physiques le code
électoral limite les dons à 4600 euros
par personne d'autres limites sont
également posées par la loi comme par
exemple le financement issu de
l'étranger ensuite les comptes sont
vérifiés dans des conditions très
strictes et déterminée par une loi de
1962 pour faire simple les comptes pour
être publié au journal officiel doit
être validée après le contrôleur
profonde est versée par la commission
qui les approuve les vosges est où les
réformes cette même commission va
également déterminer
enfin le montant des remboursements
allouées aux candidats
enfin le remboursement suit un barème
prévu par la loi fixe et est réactualisé
à chaque échéance électorale
le plafond est actuellement par
candidats de 16 millions huit cent mille
euros au 1er tour et de 22 millions cinq
cent mille euros au second tour pour les
candidats n'ayant pas franchi la barre
des 5%
4,75 % du plafond des dépenses de
campagne sont remboursés et pour ceux
qui ont réussi à franchir le cap des 5 %
le montant du remboursement s'élève
alors à 47 5% du plafond au delà les
dépenses reste à leur charge ou à celle
de leur parti ils peuvent alors lancé un
appel aux dons or ce que les pouvoirs
publics épargnants ne remboursant pas
les dépenses il est des bourses à
travers les déductions fiscales
allez c'est l'heure de sortir dans les
yvelines
avec les idées de sorties de bixente
mais rien senti très bonne justement il
est question de sortir ou plutôt de s'en
sortir parce que vous nous parlez d'un
escape game c'est ça un nouveau rendez
vous un nouveau repère de jeu pour les
amateurs d'énigmes dans les yvelines
l'escalier minos évasion vient d'ouvrir
ses portes à moins que la jolie voici
une petite découverte de ce qui vous
attend
[Musique]
de nouvelles portes s'ouvrent à
mantes-la-jolie que vous soyez de la
famille van helsing ou non il vous
faudra résoudre de nombreuses énigmes
vampirique là on est dans la pièce de
départ la salle de dracula donc on est
sur un sac est accessible dès 7 ans
jusqu'à 6 joueurs
cette salle a été pensée pour s'adapter
en fonction du joueur
par exemple un joueur qui pourra avoir
trop peur dans la salle la difficulté
est adapté une salle qui fait déjà des
cons qui parmi le jeune public le
bâtiment est assez récent les décors
sont vraiment frappant et le si
l'ambiance avec la musique fête qui est
très peu de lumière ça aide beaucoup
dans l'ambiance qui est du coup vraiment
sympa j'aime bien aussi quand il ya des
mécanismes très originaux et là il y
avait presque que ça moi je suis
originaire de mantes et j'ai toujours
voulu parce que je n'ai pas eu une
activité de loisir donc on est là avant
tout pour s'amuser la question qui
revient le plus souvent c'est la salle
est effectivement est accessible de 7 en
mai
et les adultes disent merci elle avait
trop c'est facile pour nous donc on n'a
pas envie de le faire et c'est là que ça
devient drôle parce que des fois des
enfants vont beaucoup plus vite que des
adultes ouvert depuis le samedi 23 avril
minos évasion propose un petit bonus
pour les enquêteurs les plus hardis sur
le lancement on a un concours secret
dans le local quand le joueur passe la
porte il a des énigmes à résoudre et le
joueur qui arrive à résoudre toutes ces
énigmes pourra gagner un chèque de 1000
euros au total il y aura quatre salles
dans l'établissement de lignes sont déjà
tracées
le manoir du comte dracula et une
seconde pièce à venir dans l'univers du
film d'animation vice versa enfin les
deux dernières au sous sol dont les
thèmes restent encore bien gardé du nord
du département direction le sud ce
tournoi en yvelines avec un lieu
personnellement que j'adore bixente
c'est la maison elsa triolet aragon mais
c'est vrai que c'est un endroit sympa
pour faire une petite balade se
promenait le temps d'une journée il se
trouve qu'il ya aussi des expositions en
cependant c'est 215 propose autographes
une exposition ouverte sur place
jusqu'au 8 mai de son vrai nom christian
guémy l'artiste est un grand amateur de
poésie collectionneur de manuscrits
d'autographes d'auteur c215 a peint de
nombreux portraits dans la rue deux
grandes figures de la littérature dont
les clichés de quelques-uns qui sont
visibles à la maison triolet aragon mais
l'exigent l'exposition compte aussi des
espaces spécialement créé pour
l'occasion notamment une grande fresque
éphémère représentant le couple elsa
triolet louis aragon mais également
plusieurs portraits d'auteurs mise en
relation avec leurs écrits explications
de guillaume roux boc rachid directeur
de la maison triolet aragon qu'est ce
qu'on voit ici eh bien on voit une série
de textes c'est très émouvant de les
voir ici ont des textes de grands poèmes
qui ont été écrits par eux-mêmes l'un
des textes autographes donc là par
exemple on a un texte un grand ami
d'aragon qui est venu ici plusieurs fois
qu'est donc pas les louables par exemple
ici écrit à la main et en regard de ces
textes vous avez le portrait que
proposent ces 215 de chacun de ces
grands poètes qui forment son panthéon
un peu personnel et c'est lui qui
choisit de support par exemple là vous
voyez il ya apollinaire et 17 présenté
sur un texte qui s'appelle la dérobée et
ça fait une allusion en réalité à la
joconde puisque avec apollinaire a connu
les affres de la justice parce qu'en
sanctionné d'être liée à l'enlèvement de
la joconde au louvre au début du 20e
siècle et on parlera plus en détail
bixente de cette exposition mais aussi
de l'actualité de la maison elsa triolet
aragon dans la prochaine émission 7,8
culture vous serez exceptionnellement
aux commandes en remplacement de
selliers agathe 100 go qui est son repos
on la salue d'ailleurs célia d'ailleurs
le 7-8 culture c'est tous les mardis
soir sur tv 60 18 à partir de 18h30
deuxième semaine aussi des vacances de
printemps qui débute pour les jeun's
yvelinoise ce dimanche aussi ce sera le
premier maître michel seydoux oui c'est
l'occasion de faire une petite sortie en
famille il est d'ailleurs l'association
lyon ce club et d'elancourt organise les
premières rando solidaire à la verrière
l'objectif c'est passer un bon moment
tout en soutenant la recherche et le
développement de l'institut et mgm plus
de détails avec le responsable de cet
événement
ce week-end nous organisons des rondeaux
solidaire de l'institut ici sur le site
du château de la verrière donc il fait
partie du domaine de l'institut
mg l
ces randonnées
sont à la fois des randonnées pédestres
aînés randonnée cycliste de
cyclotourisme au total il ya six
parcours 3 pédestre et trois cyclos
il y à interdire cet établissement
une association et des soignants qui
mène des projets d'innovation
thérapeutique
les recettes de participations serviront
aussi à financer les projets en question
[Musique]
les horaires d'inscription pour ce qui
concerne les parcours de cyclotouristes
c'est à partir de 7h30 le matin jusqu'à
9 heures et pour les parcours pédestres
et de 8h30 à 9h30 on est à fixer c'est
ces tranches horaires en fonction aussi
des durées de parcours de façon à ce que
tout le monde revienne à fourmies dit
sachant 15h30 il y aura un buffet et une
collation pour l'épauler comprend pas
les concurrents mais les participants
aux randonnées les cartes deux parcours
sont disponibles sur internet on peut
les télécharger en format pdf ou en
format gpx pour ceux qui ont des gps
et dans l'agenda aussi des vacances
scolaires des retrouvailles qui tardait
bixente celle avec le beau temps alors
pas tous les jours mais au moins avec la
douceur et c'est l'occasion de faire des
sorties en extérieur oui exactement
après par exemple la petite randonnée du
côté de la verrière que vous venez de
voir on peut se tourner plutôt l'après
midi autour au bord de la seine le
nautic parc de bougival fait sa nouvelle
saison par un bal dimanche de 14 heures
à 18 heures c'est l'occasion de boire un
verre dans s'est passé du bon temps bord
de l'eau dans un cadre sympathique pour
ceux qui ne peuvent pas dimanche pas de
panique d'autres rendez vous dansant
sont prévues à plusieurs dates de juin à
septembre en complément bien sûr de
l'activité première du parc avec voilà
des rendez-vous aquatique on en
reparlera d'ailleurs bientôt dans cette
même mission le rendez vous est pris on
termine cette émission avec un mot de
sport un événement à voir oui un gros
tournoi handisport qui se prépare du
côté du vélodrome nationale ce n'est pas
du vélo mais bien du tennis de table le
sky par att french open ça sera du 5 au
8 mai prochain presque quatre cents
pongistes quand même venus du monde
entier vont s'affronter sur ces trois
jours lors d'un tournoi qualificatif
pour les championnats du monde prévus en
novembre 2022 un événement majeur donc
pour le sport est d'ailleurs les
sportifs du skipping que nous suivons
régulièrement ici atv soixante dix huit
seront présents sur place pendant les
trois jours de l'événement on peut avoir
plus d'informations vous avez pas le
site internet qui s'affiche me sur le
site du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on tape tout
simplement dans la barre de recherche
vélodrome nationale et on tombe très
facilement sur le résultat voilà c'est
la fin de cette émission merci bixente
pour ses idées de sorties bon week-end à
commercial ou grégory également vous
allez faire quoi plus bas peut-être
passé du côté du nautic parc ou une
petite randonnée il ya franchement il ya
pas mal de choses je crois que je me
réserve le font encore vous avez donné
en tout cas l'idée de sortir et d envie
de sortir à nos yvelinois alors le
retour d'information comme d'habitude
c'est à partir de lundi sur tv soixante
dix huit avec le journal de la rédaction
et d'ici là bien sûr passer un excellent
week-end
[Musique]